hello let's do some work on logarithm
properties so let's just review real
quick what a logarithm even is so if I
write let's say I write log log base X
of a is equal to I don't know make up a
letter and what does this mean well this
just means that this just means that X
to the N equals a I think we already
know that we've learned that in the
logarithm video and so it's very
important to realize that when you
evaluate a logarithm expression like log
base X of a the answer or when you
evaluate what you get is an exponent
right this n is really just an exponent
this is equal to this thing right you
could have written it just like this you
could have because this n is equal to
this you could just write X it's going
to get a little messy to the log base X
of a is equal to a all I did is I took
this N and I replaced it with this term
and I wanted to write it this way
because I want you to really get an
intuitive understanding of the notion
that a logarithm when you evaluate it
really is an exponent and we're going to
take that notion and and that's where
really all of the logarithm properties
come from so let's let me just do what
we'll actually want to do is I want to
to StumbleUpon the logarithm properties
by playing around and then later on I'll
summarize them and clean it all up but I
want it I wanted to show you maybe how
people originally discovered this stuff
so let's say that I don't know let's say
that X let me switch colors I think that
that keeps things interesting so let's
say that X to the I don't know L is
equal to a well if we write that as a as
a logarithm that same relationship as a
logarithm we could write that log
base X of a is equal to L right I just
rewrote what I wrote on the top line now
let me switch colors and if I were to
say that X to the M is equal to B and
same thing I just switch letters but
that just means that log base X of B is
equal to M right I just did the same
thing that I did in this line I just
switch letters so let's just keep going
and see what happens so let's say let me
get another color I might have to run
out of kkona I have infinite color and I
will never run out so let's say I have X
to the N you're revising Sal where are
you going with this but you will see
it's pretty neat X to the N is equal to
a times B X to the N is equal to a times
B and that's just like saying that log
base X is equal to a times B so what can
we do with all of this let's start with
with this right here X to the N is equal
to a times B so how can we rewrite this
well a is this and B is this right so
let's rewrite that so we know that X to
the N is equal to a a is this is X to
the L X to the L and what's B times B
well B is X to the M right not doing
anything fancy right now
well what's X to the L times X to the N
well we know from the the exponents when
you multiply when you multiply two
expressions that have the same base and
different exponents you just add the
exponents so this is equal to let me
take a neutral color and if I said that
verbally correct by you get the point
when you
the same base and you're multiplying you
can just add the exponents that equals x
to the I want to keep switching colors
because I think that's useful L L plus M
it's kind of ownerís to keep switching
colors but you get what I'm saying
so X to the N is equal to X to the L
plus M let me put the X here and oh I
wanted that to be green X to the L plus
M so what do we know we know X to the N
is equal to X to the L plus M right well
we have the same base we have these
exponents must equal each other right so
we know that n n is equal to L L plus M
okay what does that do for us that's I'm
kind of just been playing around with
logarithms am I getting anywhere I think
you will see that I am well what's
another way of writing n so we said X to
the N is equal to a times B oh I
actually skipped a step here so that
means so going back here X to the N is
equal to a times B that means that log
base X of a times B is equal to n you
knew that I didn't I hope you don't
realize I'm not backtracking or anything
I just forgot to write this down when I
first did it but anyway so what's n
what's another way of writing N well
another way of writing n is right here
log base X of a times B so now we know
that if we just substitute n for that we
get log log base X of a times B and what
is that equal well that equals L another
way to write L is right up here it
equals equals log base X of a plus M and
what's M M is right here log base X
of B and there we have our first
logarithm property the log base X of a
times B well that just equals the log of
base X of a plus the log base X of B and
this is hopefully this proves that to
you and if you want the intuition of why
this works out it its Falls from the
fact that bloggers rhythms are nothing
but exponents so with that I'll leave
you in this video in the next video I
will prove another logarithm property
I'll see you soon